mitch keller is his fourth start this
season is the second start coming off
the injured list last time out five days
ago against the cincinnati reds just
three innings 65 pitches walked four
nicely done strikes out goldschmidt
kwang hun kim he's 2-0 and look at the
era 0.63
in five starts this year he was the
original closer for the cardinals
sway and a mess and a strikeout to start
the game for kim
kee brian 296 a pair of homers
right-handed swinger no score first
inning
to center field hit deep vader back to
the wall and it is gone clear the deck a
cannonball for key brian hayes
and a one-nothing pirates lead
his third
in this his 17th major league game
looks like he tried to back door another
breaking ball
swing and a miss and two strikeouts in
the inning and it's one nothing
pittsburgh
kind of looking
97.
velocity is back that's for sure we saw
that
watching everything he does oh got your
eye on a guy that's uh
good movement
the good fastball back-to-back case
look out joey cora goes down
now did he move before after the ball
went by
they smiled
he's starting to move yeah
107.3
yeah that's a pretty quick reaction
there
and there's nobody on base get out of
the firing line well how about this down
the line and left enough and yes
clear the deck a line drive cannonball
coming for jose osuna his second
and it's two nothing
kim's giving up a couple home runs now
so maybe not quite themselves
tonight
good life there 96
four strikeouts for keller
strikeout for
keller back-to-back case one two three
and it's nothing bucks
and he gets another strikeout that is
six k's and what is turning out to be
one of the
most promising starts this is his 15th
in the big leagues
well you know from keller what steve
used to say if you've got some good
cantaloupes about now it's starting to
go out over the wires
3-2 pitch
and a swing and a miss
strikeout number three for kim
return now to the mitch keller story
pirates lead two nothing
and bounced to moran
has 12 straight set down and 14 of the
last 15
and tommy edmond will come to the plate
mitch keller
ground ball
two outs
well he's gonna go six without allowing
a hit
what a performance from mitch keller
that's gonna be it for mitch keller
six no hit innings and a handshake from
his manager
84 pitches
two walks one hit batter
and after 84 no hit innings
he'll be pulled
chopped to third and that will get the
job done and then some and a little bit
of trouble for edmond getting the ball
out of the glove
so everybody's safe
and a base hit for colin moran it has to
feel awfully good for the redbeard he
picks up the rbi to score a haze and on
the play gonzalez to third pirates lead
three-nothing
0-2 pitch
and a strikeout of bell so they did not
want him to hit from the left side
that'll probably be it for kim we'll see
and they'll go with the right-hander
here they've been out hit 6-0 and they
trail three-nothing jake woodford is our
call to the pin and the batter will be
jacob stallings who
the runner goes a fly ball to shallow
center long run vader wow what a catch
he makes runner at third will tag and
score
bader
covered a ton of acreage sacrifice fly
for stallings pirates lead four nothing
the 2-2
and yachty is hit by the pitch
and he's in some pain now
the bases will be loaded
he's smiling so he's going to stay in
there but this one clearly hurts he
walked miller
walk to young
hits molina the cardinals still in
search
of their first hit it's a mess right now
bases loaded nobody out sam howard
they're all loaded up for tyler o'neal
and o'neal rips it fair
on the line off the sidewall
two runs will score o'neal the second
they get their first hit they get on the
scoreboard and it's now a 4-2 game
heard a base hit could tie it
dylan carlson
with a fly ball into right good job
to make the catch
both runners tagging up yadda will score
and the speed of o'neill to third
and still only one out
peter not running and wong
gets a base hit into center field drives
in tyler o'neill
and with that it's a brand new game
it's 4-4
the 2-1 pitch to
tommy edmond
edmond
base head into left
bader is waved in
and the throw is going towards very much
the shortstop area and so the runners
advance to second and third and a run
scores and the cardinals have a 5-4
laid oh ouch that had to hurt in fact
jerry meals
has someone to come out from the dugout
waves on brian hausen immediately i'm
not even going to try and put weight on
it eric shelton uh brian house and now
ben potenciano the two trainers will
help kevin newman off the field
obviously that is
not good at all
97 miles an hour at the knee
in frazier grounds it right side wong d
young double play
it's a double play
and the cardinals win it five to four
they get the ground ball to end it with
two